So even though things are kind of grim, with regard to
solving the general sum games. There are lots of ideas that,
that have proven themselves to be pretty useful for addressing this,
this class of games. It is not the case that any one
of them has, has emerged as the dominant view, but, but
these are all really cool ideas. So here's one. You can think
about stochastic games as themselves
being repeated. So, repeated stochastic games.
We're going to play a stochastic game and when it's over, we're going to
play it again. And that allows us to build
folk theorem-like ideas at the level of stochastic games.
>> Oh, that's cool.
>> And so there are some efficient
algorithms for dealing with that. So that's
one idea. Another one is to make
use of a little bit of communication side-channel
to be able to say, hey, other player. Here's this thing that I'm thinking about.
And it's cheap talk in a sense that, it's nothing that's being said is binding
in any way but it gives the two players
the ability to co, to coordinate a little bit.
And you can actually ultimately compute a correlated equilibrium,
which is a, a version of a Nash equilibrium
that you know, requires just a, a little bit
of coordination, but can be much more efficient to
compute. And you can actually get a near optimal
approximations of the solution to stochastic games using that idea.
>> Yeah, that's
cool. Didn't, didn't I do some work in this space?
>> You did. That's where I got the idea from.
>> Oh okay.
>> There's some, some work by Amy Greenwald looking
at how correlated equilibria play into stochastic games and
then your, your student Liam and you developed a,
a really cool algorithm that actually probably approximates, the solutions.
>> Nice.
>> Another idea that I've heard a lot about lately, that I
really like, is the notion of a cognitive hierarchy. The idea that what
you're going to do is instead of trying to solve
for an equilibrium, you think about each player as assuming
that the other players have somewhat more limited computational
resources than they do. And then taking a best response
to what they believe the other players are going
to do. This turns out to be a really good
model of how people actually play when, when you
ask them to do games like this in the laboratory.
>> Huh.
>> Yeah, the good news about this idea is
that, because they're best responses, they can
be more easily computed. That, that it's more
like, cue learning in MDPs again because you're
assuming that the other player is, is fixed.
>> Okay. I'll buy that.
>> And, the last idea I want to throw
out is the notion of actually using side
payments so that the players, as they're playing
together, cannot only take joint actions, but they can
say, hey, I'll give, I'm going to get a
lot, but if we take this action, I'm going to
get a lot of reward. I'm going to give some of that reward back to you, and that
will maybe encourage you to take the action that
I need you to take so that we'll both
do better. And so there's this lovely theory by
a father and son duo that they call coco values.
Coco sounds awesome but it stands for Cooperative competitive
values [CROSSTALK] and so it actually balances the zero
sum aspect of games with the mutual benefit aspect
of games. So it's, it's, it's a really elegant idea.
>> So basically, the problem
isn't solved but there are a lot of cool
ideas that are getting us close to solving it.
>> That's right. Yeah. So even though the one player and
the zero sum cases are pretty well understood at this point, the
general sum case is not as well understood. But there's a
lot of really creative ways that people are trying to address it.
>> So, that is good news.